K cousins is my guy after watching that
QB show of who Kirk Cousins is if you
know what he puts into the game and how
he goes out there performing and things
he goes through adversity I truly was
inspired by Kurt Cousins in that
documentary they truly show light on the
person he is type of player he is and
how he represents the National Football
League I hope we see Kurt back on that
field because that guy right there is
special when he was getting carded off
the field he did not bow his head he
clapped for his teammates he still
supported everyone that's the type of
guy Kurt is I think is always bigger
than a game of football it's always
about others it's always about his
teammates and making sure they stand up
high and they're not losing
faith